i was really nervous i was really
nervous yeah
i was like i i was like sweaty
and nervous and not you know
yeah this isn't a hospital it's a cage
so uh maisie i saw you dancing a little
bit are you guys excited to finally get
to
talk about and promote this project yes
well i'm excited for people to see it i
feel like we've been
talking about it and promoting it for
like three years
[Laughter]
would anyone like to share their first
time brain
i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control has it been hard to
keep all the secrets
yeah i mean in my case everybody asked
me a bunch of very specific questions
that the trainer got and i'm like
i don't know what i can answer
although maisie i feel like you you're
kind of a pro at that from your your
past projects
oh yeah i'm very good at just being like
can't say anything and like smiling and
like smile away
this does have so many elements that
this built-in fan base
loves so much but you know it also
touches on
i think things that people are really
dealing with right now mental health
did you guys think at all about how this
movie is coming out at a time
when people are really struggling with
loneliness with mental health and
i don't know if you thought at all about
you know even your own experiences how
you've been doing in the pandemic and
and how this movie might connect for
fans i think the movie is more relevant
now
than it would have been three years ago
and i think it's actually
really cool that it's coming out now
because i i really do think it's the
perfect movie for
people to watch um they're trapped and
people are trapped and
it's really about confronting yourself
which i think a lot of people are doing
right now
um if you're not struggling in other
ways
and you almost kind of have the
privilege to self-reflect
then that's kind of what you're doing
and so
i i think this movie kind of hits all
angles of what's going on right now
the reason you survived is because
you're a very
uncommon girl it's important we find out
your power
so we can help you get better
it's very interesting what blue said
because it makes reflect
like the characters are going through
but what is beautiful i loved since i
read the script is that these characters
they're teenagers and when you're
teenager you're figuring out about life
and you're accepting who you are and
accepting others and
understanding the world and i think all
of us are going through this a lot right
now but the movie shows something
how unity is important and i think
that's what we're going through right
now so it's really important especially
for the young people to understand their
power as
a strength and then i think the movie
shows that i think it's going to be very
inspiring for a bunch of people
hopefully well and it it is so um
inclusive i mean blue and maisy how did
you guys
feel knowing that these main characters
are in this queer relationship and you
get to bring it to this mainstream movie
uh maisie i'll start with you
yeah i thought i i loved um i love
just the arc between the two of them and
the way the
rain really becomes like a different
person towards the end of the movie
since meeting danny and i think like
that is like a love story is so
is something to really look up to i
think that it's rare
um in like superhero films or action
movies that you get to see a
relationship which is like as healthy
as this one is for both parties um
but i also love that it wasn't like
labeled like these girls
are just in love with one another and
they're attracted to one another when
they first see each other and there's
no like labels or i don't think any of
the mutants ever even mention it and
it's just like
normalized and i think like it's time
for that now like we're way past
yeah we made it yeah yeah uh
blue i i guess i have to ask because i i
would ask anyone but
i don't know if you were a game of
thrones fan but were you at all nervous
like i gotta go
and kiss me now
um yeah i mean i i was a game of thrones
fan
i was one of the people who started
watching it like really really really
late though you know
like um and i was like a fan i was
really nervous
i was really nervous yeah i was like
i i was like sweaty and nervous and
not you know yeah
like i'm just gonna be honest i was
nervous but it was the weird like the
second i got in there
i mean i've never been the kind of
person i'm not like a i'm not like a fan
like i mean i i'm not i've never i've
always i've lived in l.a for so long and
i'm from california
so i think like actors and like people
are which i've just always been around
so it when i walked in i was just like
okay
it was less like being nervous and more
like this is what i want to do for the
rest of my life
and i want to work with people like
maisie so the nervousness kind of went
aside and it just turned into like being
so like proud of myself for even getting
into that room to kiss her i love that
inspirational
that's so nice i was gonna
like it doesn't matter if you're kissing
like an actor like kissing a stranger
when there's like a camera and like a
bunch of producers just like
entertain us like that's just like
uncomfortable
right well blue uh you moved past the
the
the nerves and you guys have now made
this awesome movie what would you tell
fans
uh about what it's been like to work
with these two and what they're gonna
love about the movie
it's really been like a serious
life-changing
honor i mean i've met like two i mean i
consider alicia amazing to both be my
friends now
and like people i would just hang out
with in my life and like that's really
it's cool to go do something and to come
away with friends you know
yeah um but no really because you don't
you don't all the time like
it's just work really um uh
and i would tell fans to expect also fun
like is
is it it's thrilling and suspenseful and
emotional but i think
after while i was watching it and when i
after it was finished i was like it's
just like
fun and i don't think we talk about that
enough about how
it is kind of like there's like really
silly funny moments
it's about a bunch of teenagers like
it's very self-aware
and um i think that's really cool and
it's actually just kind of
like thrilling and like cute you know
yeah
it's really exciting to see you to see
what we're saying yesterday
that even though like these characters
they're dark and they're going through
pain and like our code name was growing
pains and all that
the film with their energy it's actually
showing how you can overcome that and
empower yourself
and transforming that into something
positive instead of being something dark
but into something that is gonna propel
you to the future i think it's exciting
well i've gotta rap with you guys but i
hope you're all okay in the pandemic and
the movie's finally coming out it's
coming yes
all right good to talk to you ladies
thank you thank you lauren
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are i don't
think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
and makes you live through it until it
kills you
he's there
we can get out of this together
[Music]